hi Fabi thank you so much for joining me
you're the defending champion of this
event after winning the Armageddon game
against Reza last year uh what are some
skills that you're trained to prepare
for the event this year
I can't say I did very specific
preparation but I do like that there's
not going to be any opening Theory any
opening preparation because we can play
you know unlimited amount of positions
pretty much so it's it's a big change
from some of my last tournaments
especially the World Cup where it was
very preparation intensive and now we
can just kind of relax I guess we have a
little bit of time before the game may
be a few minutes to kind of familiar
familiarize ourselves with the starting
position and and find someone to prepare
with a little bit just a tiny bit and
that's always a fun part to explore a
new position so
um I like that format I like that it's
one of the few events where opening
Theory and preparation doesn't really
take much of a role
so
um you haven't done something you must
have trained a little bit for the event
or you must have played some training
games a little bit but of course you
cannot predict what position you're
going to get so those 15 minutes you're
saying are very important yeah 15
minutes you get before the yeah the time
we get before especially if you have a
partner who you can because of okay
we're all playing each other but we
let's say usually some team up with
someone right and if you have someone
who who's very creative
uh so then then you can really get maybe
not into the heart of the position but
you can get some fun ideas that you can
play and maybe surprise your opponent a
bit because I guess the first instincts
are usually pretty similar between
players like what's the best first move
and so on but sometimes you have some
creative uh idea and that can surprise
someone what do you think is more
important than chess 960 is it pattern
recognition visualization special
perception maybe Pawn structure yeah I
think pattern recognition kind of goes a
little bit to the takes a little bit of
a back back seat and uh yeah it's just
that like that natural feeling for where
your pieces should go even in unfamiliar
positions because of course players
train in like these familiar structures
all their lives and let's say Carlsbad
or or certain structures where you kind
of know where your pieces are supposed
to go just through seeing a lot of games
and and in in chess 960 or chest 9lx
it's uh it's totally different because a
lot of these patterns are just
completely new like you see things that
you don't normally see regular chess
just piece configurations that just
don't happen so then it's it's very much
like an Intuition or a natural feeling
something which you can't sometimes
can't even say what exactly it is that
guides you to the right move or to the
wrong move
but but definitely that's that's a very
difficult skill to have it's one that's
difficult to develop as well because we
don't really train for some of these
positions right we get very unusual
patterns
going on from the importance of
developing various skills
um is there a particular exercise did
you find uh to be effective to improve
your visualization skills
I think when when I was younger I did a
lot of calculation exercises and and
those definitely helped I think it's
good to develop those early on now I
don't really do that sort of work
anymore
maybe it's still useful I guess I guess
it is but I feel like I put the work in
when I was young and now now it's
usually a different kind of work
um but yeah visualization is of course
of course such a key factor for uh for
calculation and very often calculation
mistakes are made because once you're
the position changes so much from the
position that you're looking at on the
board then your visualization will start
to deteriorate a little bit and your
calculation will go with that so that's
that's usually where the calculation
mistakes happen it's it's rarely at the
beginning of the variation it's more
once you go deeper and deeper into
alignment
um in terms of training I think that
definitely solving positions and just
training seeing a position very
differently from what it is on the board
is going to help with that using
blindfold chess or doing a blindfold is
a good thing to do in order to to train
it or I never really did much blindfold
chess I I imagine that it's also a
useful way to train but it's not
something that I really focused on
especially when I was younger and I also
deferred to my coaches a bit because
um yeah the coach usually takes care of
what what kind of position that you're
you're supposed to be training on and
blindfold chess was never
um let's say like playing a blindfold
game but of course blindfold chess
manifests in terms of let's say you see
a position and you calculated and you
don't move the pieces on the board then
you are still visualizing so it's it's
definitely very uh transferable skills
final question Fabi Mario looking for
the most to play in this event
I can't say there's like I mean okay the
obvious answer would be Gary but I think
everyone is very interesting as an
opponent I can't say that there's like
anyone who who I'm really like a I can't
wait for that game I think they're all
going to be very tough games playing
Gary of course is a very special
experience I do wish that I had the
opportunity to to play
um in when he was at his at his Peak
right but of course I was I was just a
kid
um or even I wasn't even born when when
he was uh was world champion but yeah
that's always a special experience and
you you still feel the intensity that
that he brings to the board but I can't
imagine how it was when he was uh when
he was dominant in the Chess World and
the best player in the world and I I
guess the intensity was was
um was even greater and I can only
hear the stories of players who played
him during those during those times
thank you very much Fabi I wish you good
luck and looking forward to seeing thank
you
foreign
[Music]